hello there reject nation i am sir
gregory alba and i am lord jonald of
house humphrey we are gonna do another
video podcast for you guys we just like
the microphones that much we like the
sound of our voices one of our topper
war tiers at patreon is whatever video
your request must do and put up on the
youtubes and today comes from the man
who got the very first ever real rejects
tattoo the biggest life regret anyone
will ever have eric Horstman he was a
little bit kind of confusing on the kind
of topic i mean we did a talk like this
a while ago art versus the artist that
kind of thing but he was basically
saying something about how we tend to
overlook and/or forgive certain
behaviors from celebrities because of
who they are so that's pretty much the
top we're going to do today we won't
talk for too long i feel like because
it's a podcast we feel like we have to
talk forever at least an hour to make it
to make it a podcast we got to talk for
way too long
i'll start off by saying this something
that i didn't bring up in the art versus
the artist video it does nothing for me
as an individual i don't think it
matters let's say someone's accused of a
heinous crime whether it be sexual abuse
you know something like that as we've
all seen and when someone comes out and
says i was close to this person and they
didn't demonstrate any of this behavior
so i don't believe it or no I dated this
person they didn't do that to me
so I don't believe it to me that that
doesn't really factor in in terms of
facts because every relationship is
different you know I've been in some
very for me I've been in some
relationships that I would consider like
yeah on both sides that was a pretty
abusive relationship then I've been in
like a rigid movement I mean now I'm
like I've are nowhere near an abusive
relationship I'm the same I'm a greg in
both relationships you develop over time
and different mixtures of people
creative
in dynamics you know and we've all heard
of people who are famous like the BK
killer
BTK know BK the Burger King he kills
going in there you war the king man yeah
commercials and then to rebrand
themselves they started making the
commercials to try to lighten the mood
yeah what's going on with the BK the BTK
broiler like with that we there's more
than just him there's been so many
people who are serial killers and who
have families who just had no that's
what they did yeah zero clue where
they're like I am so shocked to learn
about this
so to eat when people come out and say
you know like like though like people
who are like I was friends with Michael
Jackson I don't believe it like that
doesn't matter like who we are behind
closed doors can vary drastically even
with our best friends even with family
members that can drastically change well
and for me I'm like that that's for you
you know like that it's like for most of
us in these situations with celebrities
we never know them meet them personally
have any kind of look behind the scene
all we know is all the public stuff and
so I feel like it doesn't ultimately
help that much for people to come out
and be like well I knew this person and
we had such in such relationship because
just things the context and the rules
all change kind of when you have a
personal relationship with somebody
doesn't make what they've done okay if
it's something really heinous but I feel
like that's for you to figure out it's
like when louis c.k all that stuff came
out there were a couple people who are
like look yeah i don't approve of what
he did but this guy's been a friend all
my life and i'm gonna help things get
better i'm gonna try and do that and
that's a point of view that I can
respect just because it's like if you
have a friend if you know somebody if
it's your personal life we've all got
something like that and that's your
business
but in terms of the overall argument of
like this is proof that they're innocent
of something no not of course not
because yet double lives are so easy to
conceal and it's so easy to not show
parts of yourself to people around and
oftentimes people you're really close to
sometimes you hide specific parts to
yourself from because you're close to
them you know
I can speak from from personal
experience I don't want to I don't go
into too much detail only because by me
talking about it puts other family
members of mine on a level of exposure
that they don't want or I'm sure that
we're I'm sure they don't want mm-hmm
but I've had a family member who on the
outside with anyone interacted with
presented this very contagious lovable
energetic personality that just seems so
kind but I've experienced firsthand and
a witness to the way this person would
treat others in a home environment at
this strong level of abuse very very
strong level and then if I've ever told
people like well here's what it was
actually like with this person on a
consistent basis when we weren't out in
public or something they would go I I
would never have thought that I would
never have suspected that it would this
person how long was this going on yeah I
don't like part of it and I for me like
what you're talking about is like that's
their personal thing of how they choose
to feel or believe you know I feel like
that kind of went hand in hand or just
on a very personal level with what
happened with uh with Mel Gibson I think
that's why I like I'm not I am I am NOT
I'm not free of being the kind of person
who's like you know like oh they've done
something bad and they should be
condemned and but then I'm there to go
away well let's forgive them you know
I've been that guy yeah well I think the
case-by-case Ness of all this makes it
hard to have a bottom-line attitude well
and I think would Mel specifically
that's why because a lot of like the
phone calls and the behaviors that to me
I was first-hand witness with with
someone in my family on a consistent
basis and because of that I'm like well
he was the person in my family was more
than that you can see the humanity and
that kind of situation yeah fathom who
the human around that might be that
doesn't make what my family member did
right doesn't make what Mel Gibson did
right or something but it's part of the
nuance of life and on my personal
subjective level on a subconscious level
too I found myself like you know like
the acts of anger or like Christian Bale
ranting like things like that that's my
personal thing where I would find myself
being like well I'm sure there's more to
you know which some people might not
call I'm just being honest like that's
just where I would come from on a layer
like that because I'm also kind of like
conceal so yeah I do
I get that and so when people come
forward for other people for forgiveness
you know it's but for me it doesn't seem
to be that in other areas is what we've
dealt with a lot with the celebrities
lately has been acts of abusing power
and sexual abuse and it seems like
people are just so our love for a
celebrity can cloud the action you know
well and to if you step away from the
more criminal aspects of this I mean
there's also the reverse in which you
know we make these decisions about who
we hate and what we disapprove of you
know based on equally flimsy information
or equally flimsy exposure you know
because it's easy to hold
Bertie's to impossibly high standards of
how we should behave and not be
forgiving of understandably human
foibles or whatever not usually not in
as high-stakes situations as like this
person is a serial abuser or whatever
but I do think that this is a
fascinating discussion because there are
you know it's like we'll decide that we
hate certain celebrities just just cuz
you know and so yeah it cuts in both
directions to a degree so it's because
we're seeing these people from afar and
only through very specific lenses were
usually seeing things that are either
sculpted or leaked impartial you know
I'm not gonna also say that there are
people who would probably lie about
something for fame or lie about being a
victim not gonna say that those people
don't exist I think in most of these
cases though I don't think they're like
with the Michael Jackson one for example
I just think the whenever these things
happen it's like who would want to drag
themselves through that if it wasn't
real Wow yeah like why would you like
for this is gonna define most of your
life from now on you know I'm not oh I'm
not a woman obviously or for I could
speak from the perspective of being a
man in American society like that I
don't know of a man who would want to do
that
you know when especially when I was
hearing about one of those one of those
men who already had a flourishing career
as with dance and choreography working
with some major artists and stuff why
they would suddenly be like well let me
just amplify my fame with this you know
like who would do that
it doesn't what do they have to gain
from it exactly people say they just
want Fame like no one's gonna really
come on not even remember their name in
a couple weeks you know yeah and the
kind of fame you get out of that isn't
glitz and glamour Fame yeah it's a geek
it's it's a like it can be humiliating
and it's so vulnerable yeah like it's
not the kind of Fame that that is in any
way enhancing a positive
image other than the ones who decide to
go you're being brave yeah but like for
me I never haven't been sexually abused
like that but for me even kind of trying
to cloud some of the abuse I've
experienced for me that's even kind of a
like I get a little bit uncomfortable
talking about that and I don't want to
be known as victim guy so yeah I can I
just when the experience is relevant and
when it matters to share it you know
like that's the appropriate time I think
and and yeah I don't know I feel like
you're always gonna have people who are
accusing those who are speaking out of
just doing it for attention or Fame and
I think I don't know a lot of those
people are in denial or or can't handle
it I don't know well that's also the
other thing I think when you when you
catch when you talk to someone who knows
the person like this documentary comes
out they interview a person who knows
Michael Jackson it's a raw time for -
inner to ask that person it's like if
someone came out and she I mean name
name any friend anyone random that we
know dance I burped dance I burger right
so give us a dance cyber who sexually
abuse someone I'm not saying he hasn't
any keep in your pants dance so if
someone said that and and for me to come
out and be like well I know him and he
know he didn't like me maybe he did
maybe he didn't this could go for anyone
I know honestly because it could for me
I feel like I'd be in a form of instant
denial because I wouldn't want to
believe that because I know this person
and I have a connection with this person
so I just simply wouldn't want to
believe that so to get a [ __ ]
reporter riccati I'm face about it right
away yeah to get your opinion it's kind
of silly to me well and yeah and
especially as it pertains to these more
you know grave transgressions and stuff
there is a pressure to have an immediate
opinion about it and oftentimes these
are complex at least I mean you know the
the transgressions are simple enough to
condemn but just the surrounding
emotions are strange and if you're
somebody who is intimately involved
you're in a whole other Club from the
rest
you know yeah exactly and do I so what
do I think that there's room for people
to grow there's room for people to
change absolutely and do I think that
forgiveness can be earned in a public
sphere yes I do it I do think there's a
certain degree of crime though like the
fact that Roman Polanski raped a girl
and has still making films
he's make sure he can't be in America
yeah but as far as the rest of the world
is money and the luxury the power and
the freedom to create and put his films
out here in the States even even though
he can't enter into the States he's
constantly bringing over big-name
American actors that were he's at to
make a movie that to me is like too much
you know
you haven't see you haven't had the
punishment I've thought about the
scenario if someone ever like if I can't
think of something I've done in my past
where someone would come out and be like
Greg did this and you know cancel Greg
or whatever I can't think of I got there
people who I've definitely probably have
done emotional harm to absolutely I feel
like all of us most likely have if
you've lived any kind of real social
life you probably have and but but if
someone came out to me and said that my
reaction for example there at one time
there was a girl who was married who
would come I don't know if she's still
married but she would she's come on the
channel and she would like we're cool
now we're actually great now but she did
admit to me that like I would make
certain especially when you know go my
right right I don't know would make
certain jokes that will make people that
would that made her uncomfortable and
she had to tell me that and and I didn't
go I didn't get defensive
I simply had me I was talking about you
were there with me when I got the
message and I just simply told her like
I'm really sorry you know I own up to
that this is
I really didn't intend to do that it was
like I didn't realize my jokes were
making you that uncomfortable so I
worked on I change I don't do that
anyway you know so this was like this is
a long time ago and so I made sure to
change that behavior but I've also
thought about the scenario someone were
to come out about me I would think
especially if I'm a super if I'm a super
famous person and I'm having all this
fame and glory and you're seeing my face
pop up on billboards advertisements the
internet you're seeing me the person who
inflicted harm onto you created trauma
appearing in your spectrum without me
without you wanting me to and being
elevated exactly a people around and
then if you were to come out and say
something about me I feel like I would
probably have sympathy for you and be
like oh I'm sorry and you're right
because how is it fair if I'm you know
having all the glory and you have to be
witness to me you're living with all
this trauma that hasn't been resolved
and every time you see me it's a trigger
yeah you know like yeah it's on my job
to change you it's not my job to heal
you that's whatever doing you'll have to
do and I probably whatever harm I
inflicted I'm probably not altogether
healthy or wasn't healthy at that time
but that the idea of how we shift to
should they still have a career but we
never focus on the fact that the reason
this person spoke out is because they're
so [ __ ] traumatized by by the [ __ ]
they went through that we we immediately
go to the good as a career you're gonna
sustain because should they come back
instead of like no the whole point of
all this is to focus on these people are
traumatized and they're speaking out now
and the whole point is to heal and let
other people feel comfortable to
identify and have a voice as well so
they can heal - yeah one all of this
this is what podcast before
Tumi's yeah I I again seeing it from
both angles the way that we can be
overly forgiving of people whose work we
admire and people who you know as
presence at least is important to us and
we can also be overly harsh and critical
towards these people all this
has kind of brought me to a place where
it's distance made me want to stop
idolizing people so much and I was
getting tired of this all right it's
like not that she's done anything
terrible to my knowledge but you know
it's like when Jennifer Lawrence really
started to blow up and she was like a
culture meme and it was like I [ __ ]
love her so much and you know people get
ravenous about celebrities that they
like and that creates just to me it
creates a whiplash because if something
happens you have so much further to fall
when you put somebody up on a pedestal
and you just think they're the greatest
thing and so all of this you know the
the the good the bad and the you know
unnecessary has all sort of led me to
this place where now I admire certain
people's work I admire certain people's
philosophies and there are certainly
celebrities that I like and that I
follow but I've really made an effort
now to try and let go of that
idolization that intense enthusiasm that
Mema fication even of certain people and
to try and remind myself that okay
everyone is probably you know for the
most part everybody ism is just as
mundane and disappointing and exciting
and fascinating as everybody else is and
even though I only see certain amounts
of people when they're doing the
extraordinary thing they do acting in a
movie playing music on stage whatever it
is most of their life is just spent not
doing that being themselves you know
working day in and day out on things and
so yeah I feel like maybe some of these
things can get better the less we'd do
elevate people to a god-like status and
create this conundrum for ourselves when
that comes called into question or when
people just do things that are human and
imperfect - because I think that's also
a lower stakes aspect of this is just
human imperfections often get called
into question in a way that we would
never do to each other just as friends
or you know in our daily lives you know
I feel like you approach people you know
intimately with a lot more nuance and
understanding than a celebrity you see
from afar from whom you expect one type
of thing you know
you know who's it's really getting on my
nerves that's that
ian's yeah comedians hue like feel like
there shouldn't be a line and be
comedians who are instantly like wanting
to go and defend mmm their comedic
friend who did something [ __ ] up you
know yeah I'm hearing a lot more
comedians coming to the coming forward
with louis c.k mm-hmm you know of like
you guys don't think he suffered he lost
30 million dollars she lost his shows he
lost all these things I'm like yeah I I
get that I do but then when you're
following it up with a defense for the
act like a lot of her several comedians
come forward and say and defend even the
actions that he did saying there was
more to the story than that you know
there was a lot of flirting going on
leading up to that and everything you
know like they're there they're there
defending the action now and I think
like these are some major command if you
guys fall enough for these comedians
podcast you see I started off with
talking about if you've made it this far
into my weird stream of consciousness of
thoughts that are not fully cohesive it
don't II one minutes in here
I started off with talking about when
people come forward and say I was close
to this person and they didn't
demonstrate any of that because they're
you know they have a connection with
them and they don't want to believe it I
started off with that because I that's
exactly what we do as fans and admirers
of people's artistic work in film or
music or what-have-you
because like with Harvey Weinstein no
one gave like no one was like well you
know Harvey people didn't do it because
he's a producer he's behind the camera
it's specifically for it's just like
Bryan Singer even you know like there's
a certain degree there were that's rude
that's there's a certain but when you're
an actor or a musician
we have a connection with emotional
expression is part of why we know you
exactly when you like when I watch a
movie of someone who's on screen I am
connected with that artist I have formed
a connection with that person and
because of that we instantly don't want
to believe that they're capable of doing
that thing we don't want we want to we
just want to forgive them you know
because we're like the people who go I'm
friends with this person as I had a
connection with them and as fans it's
what we do with these actors and
whatever yeah because we have because
that's the thing is we have partial
evidence and your brain is immediately
gonna go to that you know and and that's
why it's always kind of a bad position
to be in because as an audience member
you just don't have anywhere near the
full picture you have the best parts of
the picture you have the parts that are
intended to get to you and they're not
the complete story so yeah when
something truly bad happens I don't feel
like we all really have as much room to
comment necessarily as we think we do
like I feel like you can approve or
disapprove and kind of state your reason
as to why but you know yeah people will
just take this ownership as though they
intimately just because you're attached
to somebody it is almost as if now
they're an intimate family member to you
and they're not you know and and you are
not in that same position that somebody
who has known this person for 20 years
and is having to deal with this is you
know I'm sure there's always more to a
story of course there's always more to a
story and few people are a hundred
percent bad you know it's just that some
things that people do in Seibert he is a
terrible terrible Seibert trust Oh trust
him just so I can object I object you
will have no I
you guys have no idea what this guy's
you let me lay it on you now I could
have I could have done this a lot sooner
and saved us all the trip but I needed
to take a platform I feel like yeah I
mean
well more is there like we've talked
about art versus the artists and such
and is it's a case by case scenario for
so many of these people I think you
should always at least a little bit
separate the art from the artist even
the art and artists that you really like
and aren't problematic you know there
should always be a line there yeah
absolutely you conclude this John I
don't know I feel like we've kind of
touched on this issue as much as we need
to Italy I feel like I'm a little over
the place and I'm not exactly aligned
with my thoughts on this is because like
this is a very exhausting topic by this
point you know I'm going to the arbors
the artists the podcast I was very like
mmm and then here it's a little bit more
of an in-depth version of the
forgiveness angle and it's exhausting
because you know we what we do we're
exposed to like mourning and people who
don't do what we do or if consul expose
social media probably even more so
because you know like and it's like
opinion upon opinion upon opinion and
and am like we all we all out to have
our opinions it's when we're trying to
control the situation or maneuver the
direction of an outcome when it's not
our place you know we're not involved
really like we will have our opinions
but it matters to your friends and
family what you think of one of these
situations because it just tells them
about your character but it ultimately
doesn't really matter that much that we
all comment on louis c.k I mean don't
maybe support his comedy now but the
Johnny Depp Amber Heard situation was
one of a [ __ ] exhaustion for me
because like I'm dealing with people on
Twitter about it who want to send me
these cases and stuff and I'm like if
you guys really believe there's more to
this story then you'll know that in so
many big profile cases just look at our
president for example who's getting a
bottom line all right
Republic he's on tape he's on he said it
he says things that we would cancel
regular celebrities for an hour so many
things that have
Reuven he's done Oh illegal or morally
corrupt things and yet he's still
president okay
and so like with the giant dip Amber
Heard thing do I know for sure what
happened no I don't and honestly neither
do any of you and that's between them we
can all have an opinion of I thought
Johnny Depp did it I don't think Johnny
Depp actually did it
I think amber Hertz [ __ ] up I think
amber herds brave we can all have that
opinion but we're trying to like [ __ ]
create the movement and we put those
people on probation just [ __ ] just
let them deal with it
let them handle let them conclude the
situation and then we'll figure out what
to do with that
yeah the court of public opinion is a
weird place to be because there's
there's no real like judge of public
opinion
yeah it just is a bigger cloud around
this nucleus for all I know Johnny Depp
can dine the funny thing is I know
people who actually know Johnny yeah and
who who are you know obviously on his
side because they know Johnny Depp and
I'm not gonna bother to waste of breath
arguing with them about the situation
and the thing is with that I'm like well
maybe ya pondered he's a very wealthy
guy maybe they paid I'm paid off a lot
of different situations in this area
maybe you didn't and I don't know if I'm
ever gonna know we don't know yeah and
it's up to us to decide what would
really goes on here on out I I think
it's kind of messed up on the Amber
Heard spectrum when an ex girlfriend of
hers comes forward like she was abusive
to me and goes see she's a really
abusive one but I'm like but but why are
you taking her word
duly noted character reports or earthing
but at the same time it's not the be-all
end-all where's that X is crazy evidence
for you or is it just for you to help
you go see I still can love Johnny Depp
and and and the thing is like for that I
like
I'm at the point where I'm like maybe he
did maybe die I die I don't know I
wouldn't be surprised I imagine
something in most of these situations I
imagine something I've heard reports
where she's done some messed-up stuff
like honestly my my honest conclusion my
opinion on it would flat-out just be I
have a strong impression they were both
pretty abusive to each other no thanks I
get
does it make him hitting her okay does
it make the report that showed that he
cut her finger it cut his finger okay no
they were both probably pretty abusive
to each other and that's between them
and we bring sometimes the relationships
bring out the worst in one another if
he's not fucked-up to anyone else and
she's not fucked-up to anyone else then
maybe we can just move forward you know
yeah and if you're uncomfortable with
what we know now you just don't have to
support either one yeah you know and
anyway I mean that's that that's the
ultimate thing as we we all think that
we know and we hear parts of the story
and this is the thing that flummoxes me
the most is when you see something like
the Michael Jackson documentary and you
have people who just won't even
entertain the idea that you know that
example that everybody has harped on
like the idea that a grown man having
children in his bed at all is kind of
strange and and people will even go so
far into denial to pretend like all that
is fine and when we get to that point
that's when I start to get concerned and
worried because it seems like willfully
Michael Jackson thing is what's when I
heard about this documentary when all
those things are coming out on Twitter
at least when I as I first heard about
it before I looked into what the all the
detailed accounts were when I first
heard it I was like Michael Jackson a
pedophile this is a noobs I thought we
already concluded that if for some
reason for gaming I I grew up in the 90s
thinking like oh he's that famous singer
that for some reason we've let him get
away with yeah I feel like they didn't
find anything of great conclusive you
know quality has never landed so we all
just kind of like with these sexual
abuse cases it's super hard to find yeah
it's very
very difficult because most of the time
it's an act between two people in an
isolated place where there's no
witnesses and no when you want to just
go innocent until proven guilty I'm like
it's it's very [ __ ] hard to like
prove that I think innocent until proven
guilty is very III abused term well it's
it's a poor term because it's
oversimplified I get it I get the point
that we shouldn't just go well there's a
suspicion you're guilty but at the same
time we shouldn't go well there's no
proof that you're guilty so you're
innocent it should be like unpro bation
until we find out what the hell happened
here and and for me my attitude on these
things has sort of become you know where
there's smoke at very least I know
there's smoke and for some reason
there's gotta be smoke whether it's a
fire or not a fire I know that there's
smoke and I'm breathing it in now so I'm
aware that there's an issue at the very
least and whether or not I get a
conclusion as to where that smoke came
from again as we touched on in the last
podcasts on this topic it's like those
things just take root in my mind and so
afterwards I'm just aware of them and
you know you decide kind of based on
that but I I wish people yeah would be
at least a little more open to the idea
of going I don't know exactly what
happened we haven't reached a conclusion
but yes it seems as though something
less than average normal Pleasant is
happening here you know because then
because that's the the truly scary thing
about this is when people just deny it
it is unfathomable that anything bad
could have happened at all you know yeah
I mean if you choose to
I get more upset at the people who you
get who keep getting work when something
is wrong like if you will if you're so
if if if you're someone who like wants
to keep watching it you know Roman
Polanski's old films before all this
stuff came out example if you want to
keep listening to louis ck's old
stand-up comedy routines you know yeah
I'm not gonna argue with you
like okay fine go ahead listen to it
what upsets me more is like the thing
that upsets me more is people who keep
hiring like I heard Bryan Singer was
released from Red Sonja I think that's
what I heard finally but but the thing
is the fact that they hired him and for
a minute were like no we're
making this yeah we want Bryan Singh
after all that they're the ones I
actually get the most upset at the once
we're still employing these people
that's when I get yes if you want to
keep watching their work that's already
out there that's a whole other subject
it like those that that's where a look
is a big it it's another topic because
it already exists it's already been
supported theoretically if you own it
you own the gray area that happens a lot
of this is like whoa are we gonna
condemn someone for how they were in a
in a one-on-one a personal private you
know boyfriend-girlfriend marriage
situation but because it's not the same
as looking at how someone abuses power
with sexual abuse and all those areas
like a Harvey Weinstein or a louis c.k
that's that's different and that doesn't
minimize any of the harmful negative
effects that a person does in a
relationship per se however it is a
different territory yeah there's a
difference between being kind of a
shitty person but not doing anything
truly criminal and being shitty person
and a criminal that's why I'm saying
when you should be in jail for the thing
that you did rather than just oh that's
an ugly situation like the Chris
Hardwick or the Johnny Depp that was
situations and when people come forward
and be like you know Chris Hardwick I
know him he's a good guy or Johnny Depp
I know him he's a good guy Amber Heard I
know I'm like well that doesn't matter
because it's not that relationship okay
cool I liked him before all this already
and I got these senses but the new thing
to me is is the relationship that you
weren't a part of the relationship it
could be totally different you could be
like the nicest person and truly a great
human being to strangers everyone you
work with your best friend all your
family members but in your relationship
it's [ __ ] up it's so it doesn't matter
you know yeah yeah it's up to us to
decide whether the weight of how they
are in that relationship like the Chris
Hardwick stuff remain reading that oh
that was that was something
yeah it was defense and you know they
investigated and it went on Wow yeah
totally and I yeah like Chris Hardwick
Johnny Depp those are I feel like those
are ones that are more left or even Aziz
Ansari are more left to us because yeah
those are necessarily criminal acts but
they are unsavory and they are not the
kind of conduct you would hold a friend
to it's not something you would want
somebody to demonstrate to you you said
the word criminal and I feel like a lot
of us come down to that because that's
where the whole innocent until proven
guilty thing comes down to is the
criminal act but we got to think about
morally corrupt things too yeah we got
to think about the moral that's why I
think what the word progressive is
really being thrown out there a lot and
that's an important element of being
progressive because that's more than
money and law and whatever it's it's
it's about who we are as human beings
yeah that's progression our society yeah
you know I'm obviously exhausted from
this and I believe 400 like 30 minutes
exactly sharp right now is kind of
worrying me but I know it's also a very
different topic as opposed to a movie
fight yeah so I don't know any any
parting words cancel everyone no more
celebrities just art no artists let me
ask you this if you found out that a
person who is a sexually abusive pervert
was your waiter at a restaurant would
you want them to be your waiter at the
restaurant yeah you know but for some
reason now famous actor that's different
that's a more important thing when
really it's just a job well that's the
double that's the double-edged sword of
being removed because I think that is a
good question yeah is like if I actually
had to be in a room with this person
though then how would I feel because
it's really easy for me to never meet
them and just rent a movie love the
actor director that is Malcolm
well and and I I don't know exactly what
the right answer is about Mel Gibson
specifically but I think there are some
problematic people out there for whom
you can say yeah I wouldn't want to meet
or spend time with this person but I do
recognize the quality in their work and
I can separate the two of them and I am
NOT you know the way I consume their
thing isn't actively helping to destroy
anything or or whatever or if you have
to you can offset your it's like I think
if you you know just gotta go see a Mel
Gibson joint and you feel conflicted
will donate to something that that is in
the interest of you know helping
domestic violence or things like that
you know I don't know it's it's it's I
feel like we're all figuring out as a
newly informed and a newly connected
society what we're supposed to do in
these situations and I also feel like we
ought to maybe stop attacking each other
quite so hard as we figure out what to
do about these things yeah we're not
gonna I don't I don't see in our time
and our what's the word for it I mean I
like I feel like internally I'm an
idealist and I don't think in our time
on this planet we will see a time where
communication is that good I don't think
in our lifetime we will know I like to
keep working towards it I'd like to be a
part of the of the group that works
towards that though yeah because get as
many people down for that cause as
possible I feel like social media like
people say like Oh social media has ruin
like actually it's it's always sort of
been that way it's just changed the
scope now everyone can just put their
voice out there a little more evidently
now yeah and that's about it but it's
there's a place for all these thoughts
not like social media happened and then
we turn into this person yeah it's just
a loud platform for all the things we
weren't saying before and all the things
that we would have to save up to the
point where we were on the phone with or
in the marum with somebody yes it
worries me of of how the youth respond
to this and how the youth feel influence
and inclined and feel like they can
behave a certain way because for us to
have this but this perception of this is
weird and [ __ ] up the youth growing up
in this this is normal and acceptable
and okay when you know like it's not so
yeah well and they used to either the
youth speaking like a old old fogies
here but I say yeah I mean the
influential brain of the young kids yeah
you know but the other the flipside of
that is that we have seen more you know
young people like people who aren't even
a voting age now more than ever are at
least taking an interest in current
events in society and you know at least
taking some sort of stand earlier than I
feel like we would have you know without
all this connectivity so it there is I
think hope at least for some of this
yep because yeah it's it's hard it's
always gonna be an issue of who you grew
up around where you got your education
from how much education you got you know
what experiences you've had with people
who aren't like you what you know yeah
yeah there's there's always gonna be a
million factors anyway guys who do you
forgive forgive and who have you
cancelled subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell most people
probably haven't made it to this this
far but if you did you win a prize yeah
so we'll let you know see you guys peace